es ist wirklich zu verrückt um wahr zu
sein science fiction pur doch so
genannte zeit kristalle sind realität
ein wirklich bizarrer neuer
materiezustand der die fachwelt in
aufregung versetzt zeit kristalle sind
in der lage sich zu verändern und das
ohne dabei energie zu verbrauchen ein
forschungsteam von google behauptet
jetzt an solchen zeit kristall selbst
hergestellt zu haben und das wäre der
wissenschaftliche durchbruch überhaupt
für konnten computer ermöglicht das
vollkommen neue perspektiven klicks zum
science in future gibt drei mal pro
woche spannendes heinz videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen zeit kristalle sind
ziemlich verrückt aber realität in der
theorie wurde diese völlig neue art der
regelmäßigkeit bereits vor einigen
jahren aufgespürt anders als normaler
kristalle die sich im raum periodisch
verhalten verhalten sich zeit kristalle
achtung periodisch in der zeit ihre
bausteine bilden wie in einem normalen
kristall regelmäßige gitter doch ihren
zustand verändern sie in einem
regelmäßigen takt das gitter existiert
in derzeit nicht im raum lange zeit galt
das als unmöglich ohne äußeres zutun
ändern die bausteine derzeit kristalle
also ihren zustand möglicherweise ist
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern von google in diesem
zusammenhang jetzt ein
wissenschaftlicher durchbruch gelungen
das forschungsteam wir bewiesen haben
dass es menschenmöglich ist zeit
kristalle herzustellen für die
entwicklung von quantencomputern wäre
das ein revolutionärer meilenstein ihr
einsatz in der praxis könnte damals in
greifbare nähe rücken so die hoffnung
wie kann man sich einen solchen zeigt
tristan also vorstellen und wie genau
verlief das experiment der gugl
fachleute alle spannenden infos zu
diesem thema gibt es jetzt hier bei
pixum science and future kristalle die
vielleicht ordentlichsten orte der welt
in ihrem inneren ordnen sich atome und
moleküle von selbst zu sehr regelmäßigen
strukturen an die sich immer wiederholen
in der fachsprache ist von einer spontan
gebrochenen räumlichen symmetrie die
rede doch schon vor einigen jahren kam
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
in theoretischen überlegungen auf den
gedanken dass es eine völlig neue art
der gesetzmäßigkeit geben könnte
basierend auf einem grundlegenden aspekt
von albert einstein nach dem raum und
zeit eng miteinander verwoben sind
gemeint sind sogenannte zeit kristalle
die sich eben nicht im raum sondern in
der zeit periodisch verhalten der
theorie nach könnten die bausteine
solcher zeit kristalle periodisch ihren
zustand ändern und das ohne äußeres
zutun als entdecker der zeit kristalle
gilt der physik-nobelpreisträger frank
wilczek der vor neun jahren 2012 der
symmetrie von materie in hinblick auf
die zeit auf die schliche kam er war es
also der die zeit kristalle in der
theorie vorhersagt 2017 dann endlich die
erkenntnis dass raumzeit kristalle
tatsächlich existieren wir hatten hier
bei pixum darüber berichtet das
forschungsteam aus den usa schrieb
damals dazu unsere arbeit enthüllte die
physikalische basis dafür wie solche
zeit kristalle funktionieren könnten die
atome bewegen sich dabei in der zeit
aber klappt dies fließend oder in einer
kontinuierlichen weise zu tun bewegen
sie sich periodisch und weiter heißt es
als fazit mit der schaffung der zeit
kristalle haben wir einen neuen
materiezustand geschaffen und so den
katalog der möglichen ordnung in raum
und zeit um einen eintrag erweitert doch
gibt es einige herausforderungen die die
erforschung der zeit kristalle
kompliziert macht die strukturen waren
lange zeit nur wenige nanometer klein
und bildeten sich nur bei sehr kalten
temperaturen von unter minus 250 grad
celsius dennoch ist das interesse an den
zeit kristallen riesig groß denn wenn
man es mal auf den punkt bringen können
sie ihren zustand hin und her
verschieben ohne dabei an energie zu
verlieren im klartext heißt das also
dass er sich bis in die ewigkeit
verschieben könnten ohne ihre materie
dabei zu erschöpfen handelt es sich also
um eine art perpetuum mobile und mit
zwangsläufig der zweite hauptsatz der
thermodynamik gebrochen wird tatsächlich
umgeht man mit einem zeit kristall den
heiligen gral dafür sieg denn der zweite
hauptsatz der thermodynamik sagt
eigentlich dass systeme mit der zeit
immer unordentlicher werden das
universum bewegt sich in der klassischen
physik also immer in richtung entropie
so wird diese unordnung bezeichnet also
ganz einfach wenn eine vase auf den
boden fällt dann geht sie kaputt und
wenn man scherben auf den boden fallen
lässt dann werden sie nicht zu einer
vase das heißt die tendenz geht immer zu
der unordnung und nicht in richtung
ordnung ja und weil das ganze eigentlich
zu krise ist um es zu verstehen jetzt
noch einmal zusammengefasst regelmäßige
kristalle bilden ein singuläres muster
im raum während zeit kristalle ein
singuläres sich wiederholen das muster
in der zeit bilden dabei können sie
ihren zustand ohne verlust der eigenen
energie hin und her verschieben weil
zeit kristall handelt es sich also um
einen neuen materiezustand andere
bekannte phasen der materie wie etwa
wasser oder eis befinden sich im
thermischen gleichgewicht ihre bausteine
sind eingelagert in dem zustand mit der
niedrigsten energie die die
umgebungstemperatur zulässt hier ändern
sich die eigenschaft neben nicht mit der
zeit wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler weltweit legen vor allem
bei der entwicklung von quantencomputern
große hoffnung auf zeit kristalle und
ihre eigenschaften möglicherweise
während zeit kristalle in der lage ultra
leistungsfähige quantencomputer mit
energie zu versorgen die ihrer hilfe
könnte man möglicherweise hardware
entwickeln die umfangreiche berechnung
viel schneller ausführen kann als ein
standard supercomputer und genau aus
diesen gründen haben eben auch die
fachleute von google ein großes
interesse an zeit christ halten denn
quantencomputer gelten als das große
ding der zukunft sie sind nämlich in der
lage aufgaben nicht nur schneller
sondern auch deutlich effizienter zu
lösen als herkömmliche computer das
alles basiert auf super spannenden
quantenphysikalischen phänomen
quantencomputer könnten viele komplexe
probleme der menschheit lösen und
anwendung in zahlreichen verschiedenen
bereichen sind denkbar in der
medikamentenforschung für berechnungen
in der logistik der finanzwirtschaft bei
künstlicher intelligenz oder
datensicherheit ein quanten internet
über das gespeicherte information über
große entfernungen ausgetauscht werden
könnte sogar eine neue ära der
kommunikation einleiten zu schön um wahr
zu sein der gugl quantencomputer mit dem
namen super moore arbeitet wie alle
quantencomputer mit so genannten cookies
es handelt sich um quantenteilchen die
sich gleichzeitig in zwei möglichen
zuständen befinden können die kumpels
von super more sind supraleitende
aluminium strafen jedes cupid hat zwei
mögliche energiezustände die so
programmiert werden können dass sie
spins also dreh impulse darstellen die
entweder nach oben oder unten zeigen die
fachleute verwendeten in ihrem
experiment einen chip mit 20 solcher
kubitz der also als zeit kristall dient
mit einem mikrowellen laserstrahl wurden
strafen beschossen die fachleute hatten
den spins beliebige anfangs
konfiguration gegeben beispielsweise
oben oben unten oben unten und so weiter
durch den beschuss des systems mit
mikrowellen drehten sich die nach oben
weisenden spins nach unten und umgekehrt
diese wurden viele male für jede anfangs
konfiguration demonstriert und die
zustände der kumpels nach
unterschiedlicher zeit in jedem
durchlauf gemessen so konnten die google
fachleute offenbaren dass das pin system
zwischen zwei zuständen hin und her
wechselte nachdem die fachleute dass
viele male hatten durchlaufen lassen und
immer an verschiedenen stellen stoppen
konnten sie eine extrem spannende sache
feststellen das system kippt zwischen
zwei bestimmten zuständen hin und her
oder anders gesagt nach zehntausenden
durchläufen fanden die forscher heraus
dass die sammlung aus googles zwischen
nur zwei konfigurationen hin und her
wechselt zudem offenbarte sich dass die
qubits keine wärme aus dem
mikrowellenstrahlung absorbierten die
unordnung beziehungsweise entropie des
systems blieb unverändert der so
erschaffen derzeit kristall switched
also zwischen zwei ganz bestimmten hoch
energetischen konfigurationen hin und
her die fachwelt versetzt dieses
experiment in aufregung möglicherweise
google somit eine ideale plattform
erschaffen um zeit kristalle noch
genauer ins visier zu nehmen dennoch
gibt es noch einige herausforderungen zu
bewältigen denn wie alle quantensysteme
muss der gugl quantencomputer perfekt
von seiner umgebung isoliert sein um zu
funktionieren wichtig außerdem bei aller
euphorie das paper des forschungsteams
befindet sich gerade noch im sogenannten
peer review prozess die überprüfung
dieser spektakulären ergebnisse sich
andere fachleute ist damit also noch
nicht erfolgt und das so genannte peer
review verfahren steht somit noch aus
das ist eine qualitätssichernde maßnahme
bei der unabhängige forscherinnen und
forscher studien nach objektiven
kriterien bewerten möglicherweise wissen
wir also bereits nach einer offiziellen
begutachtung genaueres zeit kristalle
erschaffen ein komplett neuer
aggregatzustand da habe ich über die
entdeckung der zeit kristalle berichtet
also anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
geht mit dem abo button unter jedem
video ist kostenlos und macht schlau bis
dann bleibt dran